As an example consider this
portfolio where we have Google,
Apple, Gold, and Exxon from the
beginning of 2010 to the end of 2010.
This is what the performance of
that portfolio would look like
in the blue line, if we had
an equal allocation to each asset.
So, we gave 25% to each of those
stocks at the beginning, and
then we observed at the end,
the total performance.
And we include a chart here for
S&P 500 for comparison.
Now, this is an un-optimized portfolio.
Here's what it would look like
if we optimized for sharp ratio.
Look at that.
Look how much
higher performance we get compared
to our benchmark S&P 500.
And observe over here
the allocations to the assets.
60% goes to Gold, 40% to Apple and
none to Google or Exxon.
Now, one thing to emphasize here is,
this is looking back in time,
so we're looking back historically.
What happened in 2010 and
observing at the beginning of 2010,
if we knew what we knew now,
how should we best allocate?
So, there's a question as to
how much this can help our
portfolio going forward.
And I'll give you that
answer ahead of time.
Indeed, when we optimize for
sharp ratio, hold that portfolio,
rebalance, in other words re-optimize
that sharp ratio and continue that month
by month, we very often,
most frequently see that that improves
the performance of the portfolio
versus just an equal allocation.
But I do want to observe that
this is computing back in time,
so, yes, of course we can
find a better portfolio,
but indeed it helps
going forward as well.